good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press and
public i welcome you to this meeting of
the council thursday 7th february 2019
if i can just run through the
housekeeping quickly if the fire alarm
is activated please vacate the offices
via the stairs either through the
security doors to my right or opposite
the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lifts
please assemble in holy square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise when it is deemed safe to return
to the chamber
i can confirm the proceedings of this
meeting will be recorded and
subsequently
broadcast on the internet
i would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their image captured i
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if they are
our children present
i won't ask the next question which is
does anyone intend to film the meeting
i have been to spec savers
any member of the public who objects to
the possibility of being filmed may wish
to take this opportunity to leave the
meeting any filming or recording will
not be permitted for any item of
business where exempt or confidential
information
is considered following the exclusion of
the press and public from the meeting
can i ask everyone present to please
ensure that their mobile phones are
turned to silent and that they are not
used to make or receive phone calls in
the chamber whilst the meeting is in
progress
we can move on to the agenda and agenda
item one is apologies for absence
i've so far received apologies from
councillors dixon falcon grove larkins
shank schtummerschmerzing
town and hillman and our pots
are there any other apologies council
fairgrounds
thank you
okay
can i announce before we get to
the next agenda item
that a agenda item
six budget
2019-20 report has been withdrawn from
this evening's meeting
i would ask the leader to explain the
circumstances council bayford yeah thank
you chairman um i mean members will be
aware that um i've said all along for a
long time that
we couldn't carry on uh with the
never-ending saga of the port of
ramsgate and we had to reach a point
where we either had an operator and
therefore income to meet the cost or we
had to actually make the very
uncomfortable decision to actually close
sections of the port and make serious
cost savings
but today i had a conversation with
chris grayling secretary of state
department of transport
the dft is continuing commercial
discussions with seabourn and other
potential operators recognising the
importance of ramsgate port in terms of
brexit resilience the department for
transport is very keen to keep the
option of ramsgate alive and in the
light of this i'll ask the chairman to
withdraw the item tonight for it to come
back at the soonest opportunity when
those discussions have been concluded
thank you
can the leader or yourself tell us when
the last date for the actual
verification of the budget can take
place
council of athens sorry i'm told legally
the 11th of march we have to allow
sufficient time to get the council tax
decision for it to be implemented okay
thank you we'll continue with the
agenda items and agenda item two is
minutes of the extraordinary meeting
held on the 27th of november 2018
i move that the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of the council
held on the 27th of november be approved
and signed as a correct record
with the vice chairman please second
second lecture
do members agree
thank you
agenda item three minutes of the meeting
held on the 6th of december 2018
i move that the minutes of the meeting
of the council held on the 6th of
december 2018
be approved and signed as a correct
record
once again with the vice chairman plea
second second here do members agree
thank you
general item 4 announcements
it is with regret that i have to
announce that former councillor simon
morse has recently passed away mr morris
was a conservative councillor from 2007
to 2015 and a cabinet member for
environmental services
sadly
it is also with regret that i have to
announce that former councillor ronald
hatton has also recently passed away mr
hutton was a conservative councillor
from
1991 to 1994.
i'm sure the council will join me in
expressing sympathy to both mr moors and
mr hutton's family
could all members please stand for a
minute silence as a mark of respect for
the late mr moors and mr hutton
thank you
does any member wish to say a few words
councillor hayden
thank you very much german
i knew and worked with um both gentlemen
but mainly with ron hutton he joined the
council
in 91 as i did
um people used to get mixed up with he
and i
because of our names hutton and hayden
was too close
the only difference was that uh ron
hotten was a multi-millionaire
and i was a vagrant from the poor side
of ramsgate
the
the situation with ron is that he wasn't
political
he just wanted to see what he could do
for the people of thanet
and
he became deputy leader of this council
and
obviously really enjoyed himself
he used to disrupt
the
agenda
in the planning
committee especially when i was chairman
of that
meeting
and he
he was a very
good nice gentleman and his family were
very very good
as for um
the other i don't know didn't know very
much about him perhaps counselor bayford
knew more where to them than i did but
simon moore was a
a different character to ron hutton
um
he was he was a very hard working
counselor
and
he
was on the cabinet
and uh did some very good work
and uh we shall mess both of these
gentlemen thank you very much jim
thank you councillor hayden council
bayford
yes thank you chairman i suppose it's
the reversal he said i mean i didn't
really know ron hubbard very well um i
mean he was here for a term became
deputy leader um and unfortunately for
him he wasn't one of the three that
survived of the 34 of us that had been
here in 95
and i think that was a great loss to
this council because uh you know was set
i mean he was passionate about the area
and uh only wanted to see you know good
happen so it's a shame that he wasn't
here for longer
um there's simon moore yes he was
colleague for eight years um both a
backbencher and a cabinet member
he was highly intelligent very
articulate when he spoke he was always
worth listening to
he was a passionate advocate for
westgate
and i suppose the only consolation that
you can take from this that he died
doing something that he really loved
flying
thank you council bayford
thank you very much um chairman um yes i
knew ron hutton as well i'm afraid i
might have been a bit of a thorn in his
side prior to the 95 elections when i
was campaigning with labour members for
pensioners bus passes and lavatories and
i'm not going to go into the gory
details but i did come one night to a
meeting and wave a red bucket around and
embarrassed for mr hutton councillor
hutton i said is this what we're reduced
to but of course i've matured since then
i wouldn't do such a thing now
[Laughter]
i really i didn't know that ron had died
and obviously our group would be very
sorry to hear that for his anybody's
family and so
but um i knew simon much more so and
simon was a formidable and political
opponent i did write to the leader and
to sir roger gail because whatever
arouse we have in here we often work
closely together outside of here and
many times both when he was in a cabinet
position or later when i was a deputy
leader and even a leader he would
contact me about issues in westgate i
know that privately and behind the
scenes he did a lot of work with
homeless people in adrian square
he would be the first to pick up a phone
to me to say
we found particularly young women we
found i'm sleeping rough and he and i
know from an officer here at the time
that he would bring down food and
blankets and be generous
as i said he was a formidable political
opponent he was an intelligent person
it's a very sad loss for your party and
for his family and i think as i say when
we have our rows in here it's what we do
outside of here that matters and we did
get the pensioners bus passes in the end
thank you
thank you council johnson
right we move on to agenda item seven
treasury management strategy statement
and annual investment strategy mid-year
review report 2018-2019
i call upon councillor gregory
thank you chairman um this mid-year um
treasury management review to report to
council is a requirement of the
chartered institute of public finance
accountancy and provides details of the
council's treasury performance to the
end of september 2018.
the treasury management strategy
statement for 2018-19 which includes the
annual investment strategy was approved
by council on the 8th of february 2018.
there are no policy changes to the
treasury management strategy statement
and the annual investment strategy that
was previously approved
the council held 47.49 million in
investment at mid-year up from 40.88 at
the 31st 80 million at the 31st of march
investment yield was 0.6 against the
seven day local interbank bid benchmark
of 0.44
the return on investment was budgeted at
62 000 but was well above budget at 136
000 by mid year
original estimate for the capital
financing requirements was 57.17 million
and at mid-year it was held down to 30.7
million by utilizing 25.4 million of
cash flow funds in lieu of borrowing
no debt rescheduling took place due to
the prevailing interest rate structure
the debt interest budget was set at 1.5
million but is revised down to an
estimated 1.2 million by year end
finally the ratio of financing costs to
revenue stream is down on both the
non-hra and the hra budgets
non-hra is down from 10.5 percent of
revenue stream to 8.6
and hra is down from 7.6 of revenue
stream to 6
this mid-year report shows good
performance in all areas and i propose
that council approves the report and the
treasury indicators shown
thank you councillor gregory is their
seconder
council bayford
members i have an apology to make i've
got a little bit carried away myself and
i've skipped agenda item five this
wasn't a deliberate mistake
so agenda item five is declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest counselor campbell i think the
collective uh
declaration of interest in the members
allowance scheme
and agenda item
we've we've already covered that sorry
yes there is already a general
dispensation in place for members of
ourselves
thank you any other declarations of
interest
once again apologies members
do we wish to debate agenda item seven
so eloquently um presented by councillor
gregory
councillor piper
thank you chairman i'm just gonna be a
tiny little bit cheeky if you'll allow
it
this forms part of
the amount of work that mr willis and
his team have done
in the last 12 months to try and work
magic
a bit like the hebrews making bricks
without straw they've done an
extraordinary difficult job
and i believe
whether we agree fully with exactly what
the outcome has has become they still
deserve the thanks of members in this
chamber for the work that they have put
in to try as i say and work
magic it's a shame and this is where i'm
being a bit cheeky and perhaps some
clearance could be given clear guidance
could be given to us
uh whether the decision to pull it was
ours or whether it was a government
decision interfering with democratic
process in this place because whatever's
happened they have not allowed elected
members in this place to do their jobs
and do them properly for the benefit of
the people of senec so thank you for
letting me express my disappointment but
also my thanks to mr willis and his team
cheeky as ever counselor piper but as
you know i tend to be quite generous but
uh
thank you um do members agree
with councillor gregory
thank you
gender item eight members allowance
scheme 2019-20
i move that the recommendation has set
out in the report be adopted with the
vice chairman please second
i second that yeah
sorry another one
thank you
do members agree oh council bayford
thank you chairman i'd like to be as
cheeky as councillor piper and answer
his question and say that it was my
request to you to postpone the budget
tonight because i thought it was the
best thing we should do it's not denying
uh democratic rights at the budget in
fact it's creating the situation will be
better informed to create the right
budget
thank you council bayford for that uh
explanation
and defense of my position
uh we're on members allowance scheme do
members agree
thank you
that concludes the business for the
meeting this evening of the council